Mathieu je connais déjà pas le chanteur
mais si tu chantes je pense que je
connais encore moi
tu m'as dit attends attends
tu m'as dit
je t'aime je te jure nous les rend plus
jamais voilà
[Musique]
le soir sur la terre
nous verrons que jamais
[Musique]
de mon premier
c'est fini merci
[Applaudissements]
j'adore non mais sérieux
Michèle Torr papa
[Applaudissements]
sortir
ils vont la mettre calme-toi
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regarde-le c'est quoi ça aujourd'hui
[Musique]
ce soir
moi je rentre jouer serrer dans mes bras
l'amour comme les instants comme c'est
la nuit tu m'as pris mes 17 ans
emmène-moi dans
[Musique]
je suis resté la
haine j'adore
je rentre je déprime je pleure
moi aussi je suis gay
dans le thème Mylène Farmer j'adore
Mylène Farmer toujours pas français
il y a pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors tu vas pas
[Musique]
je regarde
je ne suis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et Dany Brillant
on va le faire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti
[Musique]
c'était le mois de février
qu'on l'attendait on voulait l'appeler
ce matin-là il faisait froid j'avais
rendez-vous au studio et tout en
soufflant sur mes doigts disait Clotilde
traverseau avoir un seul enfant de toi
c'est longtemps que j'attendais le voir
en dit mon frère toi c'est le cadeau
dont je rêvais qu'il est ton
[Applaudissements]
avec un gage toi c'est quoi toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on arrive en hélico ça fait quand même
rigolo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis dans des bailles de foot tu vois
c'est pas compliqué quand changer dans
la foulée
la première que tu croises tu l'appelles
mon bébé je suis beau tu vois c'est pas
compliqué
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour moi il était venu je me rappelle de
ce truc là quand il avait demandé Fatou
oui c'est pour ça qu'il est devenu
zapper comme jamais c'est un souvenir
horrible
pour elle aussi
il est arrivé il est dansé mais il était
ridicule c'est ridicule excuse-moi
arrête de vouloir te donner un style
dis-nous peut-être Jean Ferrat
ah mais c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous étiez pas sur le plateau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au vent
des Landes de Pierre ce qu'il est beau
c'est pour les vivants
envers le
collera
[Musique]
qui viennent du nord
la terre
du
Connemara
qu'en suivant le ciel il en est
la plongée nous dans un lac du Connemara
[Musique]
sont arrivés dans le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la Connemara
on sait tout le temps du silence là-bas
on accepte pas
la paix des Gallois ni celle des rois
d'Angleterre
[Applaudissements]
un chanteur des années 20 c'est pas
facile moi c'est Annie Cordy
rigolo
c'est pas mal hein on dirait la soirée
du BDE
c'est normalement c'est toujours c'est
le chef du BDE qui fait ça lol allez
c'est parti ils sont en train de
chercher un laboard
sur Google
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon père il m'a tué avec cette musique
quand j'étais gamin il m'a marqué non
mais il faut mis de cet arbre j'adore
c'est pas commode annuler là bas
c'est quoi ton chanteur préféré c'est
une chanteuse c'est Clara Luciani
regarde tous les soirs mais t'as pas du
français bébé
vas-y
onneur respire encore Aya Nakamura ah
oui respire c'est bien ce que vous
voulez c'est pour Bernard Montiel
j'ai envie de la faire au téléphone non
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'appelle n'importe qui je suis sur mon
répertoire vous me dit top mais top top
je tombe sur Mathieu Delormeau
[Applaudissements]
et j'adore tu vas deux fois dans le
téléphone il y a de l'arme à Mathieu et
Mathieu Delormeau ouais il y a de la
moule connard aussi
[Rires]
vous trouvez quelque chose vous n'êtes
pas bon ça c'est qui ben moi on a chanté
Sardou hier c'est Johnny moi j'aimerais
bien Aznavour alors la bohème
on fera le jeu je vous le dis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur les plages moi qui l'ai connu toute
ma vie que le ciel du Nord
[Applaudissements]
emmenez-moi au pays des merveilles il me
semble que la misère serait moins
pénible au soleil dans les bars à la
tombée du jour avec les mains
quand on parle
merveilleuse
alors moi je suis un mec de la street
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
allez
d'accord allez en figurine allez casse
allez c'est parti
[Musique]
et la plus belle des étoiles dans les
autres je vois que toi c'est une Queens
elle dis-moi il reste une place auprès
de moi les projecteurs sur toi c'est fou
comment tu vis dans le mal et la plus
belle mademoiselle comment j'aurais fait
pour pas
dire c'est qui c'est passé
[Musique]
je voudrais pouvoir rattraper le temps
pour que tu fasses de moins que ce que
j'ai fait bon sang qu'est-ce que j'ai
fait bonsoir je sais que le passé j'ai
passé mais y'a qu'à toi je peux me
confier tu sais sympas
[Musique]
qui s'est passé je repense à toi chaque
jour j'aimerais que ce qui est cassé tu
dis que c'est fini qui a plus de nous
mais je veux pas oublier le passé
pour lire passer
et la plus belle des étoiles
[Applaudissements]